it is thursday the last day of march
a massive misjudgment british spy boss
on president putin's maneuvers plus his
views
on how russian soldiers are refusing to
carry out orders
it increasingly looks like putin has
massively misjudged the situation
i'm live in western ukraine as president
zolensky says his forces are preparing
for new russian attacks in the east as
moscow bolsters its forces in the
donbass region
cost of living crisis with bills on the
rise and the energy price cap about to
come in we speak to a pensioner and a
widow in dire straits
oh wow
wow
still processing it chris rock speaks
out about that oscars slap as the
academy reveals they asked will smith uh
to leave and he said no
on the last day of three universal
lateral flow tests in england a warning
from a disability charity the government
is showing a disregard for the most
vulnerable
well as the parole board recommends the
mother of baby p should be set free uh
we'll ask the former chair of ofsted if
decisions like this keep the public safe
also coming up on the programme for you
today wherever you're watching us around
the world
i'm glad you came i'm glad you came
sending my love ed sheeran leads
tributes to the wanted star tom parker
who's died from a brain tumor at the age
of just 33.
and here's a question for you for
thursday morning do you have any idea
what that plant is
well we'll be speaking to the first
westerner to get a glimpse of this rare
flower in the philippines about his
mammoth trek to get there
[Music]
hello everybody very good morning to you
we start with an intervention from a spy
boss on president putin's intentions in
ukraine the uk's top spy chief that's
the jeremy fleming who is the director
of gchq has given a rare speech saying
the russian leader has made a massive
misjudgment on the capabilities of his
own military might he also claims that
putin's soldiers are defying orders and
accidentally shooting down their own
aircraft so jeremy also said the kremlin
is turning to private mercenaries to
help them in the war he said the wagner
group is going in to bolster numbers but
said they are likely to be used as
cannon fodder to try to limit russian
losses
the ukrainian president says his troops
are preparing for the russians to launch
large assaults in the east of the
country in the donbass region
it increasingly looks like putin has
massively misjudged the situation
it's clear he's misjudged the resistance
of the ukrainian people
he underestimated the strength of the
coalition his actions would galvanize
he underplayed the economic consequences
of the sanctions regime
and he overestimated the abilities of
his military to secure a rapid victory
we've seen russian soldiers
short of weapons and morale
refusing to carry out orders
sabotaging their own equipment
and even
accidentally shooting down their own
aircraft
and even though we believe putin's
advisers are afraid to tell him the
truth
what's going on
and the extent of these misjudgments
must be crystal clear to the regime
we'll be chatting to tom cheshire in
just a second in beijing but first let's
bring in uh dominic waghorn should we
are international affairs editor he's in
levitt for us this morning how should we
interpret this uh dominic good morning
morning okay well i think in some ways
it's revealing some of in some ways what
jeremy fleming is is is fairly uh
predictable and he's saying that uh the
cyber actors so he's opposite numbers on
the russian side are doing what you'd
expect them to do disrupting ukrainian
intelligence and uh military and
government systems but also saying that
could spill over into neighbouring
countries and further afield to britain
if you like also but what he's saying
about putin i think is is revealing for
months in the run-up to the invasion and
in the weeks since the invasion began
we've been trying to second-guess
working out what is going on in putin's
minds and obviously western policy
makers have been as well and flemish in
this unique position he has all this
information that gchq is feeding in
through surveillance monitoring that
gives a good picture as good a picture
possibly as we can get certainly in the
west of what is happening with putin and
what he's saying is putin has been badly
advised he has massively misjudged the
situation in ukraine in terms of what
his troops could expect invading but
also in terms of the way sanctions could
uh respond and he's saying that even
russians are shooting down their own
planes i think the concern is that this
is a
an isolated ill-advised russian leader
whose next actions are unpredictable and
therefore quite volatile
thanks very much indeed dominic let's
bring in tom as well should we from uh
from a china perspective your thoughts
from beijing this morning please tom
i mean yeah it was striking that despite
the focus on ukraine there was a lot of
room for china in sir jeremy's speech
and he warned about the alignment
between china and russia he said it
might bring risk to china as well
because russia does not play by the
global rules and china wants that
leadership role but i don't think that
will have much effect we had the foreign
minister of russia here in china
yesterday and they reiterated that
partnership they said again that it had
no limits and that had already withstood
the first test i think that speech uh
from the director of gchq saying look
the west is preoccupied it's busy with
ukraine that doesn't mean it's forgotten
about the wider world and especially the
role of china in that world and the
world to come as jeremy talks of a
generational upheaval that's how china
sees it as well it's clear that
ukraine's happening in eastern europe
but there is a wider picture here that
gchq is very much paying attention to
gentlemen thank you both uh let's bring
in the international trade secretary
anne marie trevallion with us in the
studio this morning good morning good
morning thanks for joining us uh on
scania's breakfast this morning um so
we've heard what gchq have been saying
the head of gchq uh putin obviously
coming up with a very different story
where's the government this morning so
the prime minister continues to be very
clear that putin
must fail in his outrageous and illegal
war uh in invading ukraine and uh the uk
government will continue to work hand in
glove with both our us and our eu allies
to support ukraine to defend their
territorial uh country borders and to
make sure that uh putin turns his tanks
around and takes them home
putin still has some friends amongst the
international community not least india
you were there i think in
january am i right insane and we're
looking to do a trade deal with them
later on but they refused to condemn
what was happening um in ukraine um
they don't seem to as a result be
respecting international borders do we
really want to do a trade deal with a
country like that
so the foreign secretary has gone out to
india this week
to have conversations with
her engine counterpart and to discuss
what is
a difficult situation i think for all of
us who are democratic nations in india
of course is the largest democracy in
the world uh that
standing up
for democratic nations and peaceful
borders which
ukraine's have been
breached is something that we want to
see uh everyone doing and i know that
liz trust will be uh continuing to have
those discussions uh with the ministers
in india to do that uh our trade talks
are altered at a relatively early level
at the moment and officials uh met uh 10
days ago for some discussions which are
progressing uh but we're you know we
will continue those uh for the time
being as as we have several trade deals
uh on the go and see how we progress but
it's really important
that we see india we understand why
they've chosen to sit on the fence at
the moment they uh you know have
connections in both directions but
for us it's really important to see all
countries who believe in democracy and
the rule of law
and indeed defending your own
territorial borders and wanting to have
that sovereignty you know respected by
those around you to stand up for that
but does it really sit comfortably with
you doing business with a country that
by a mission is sanctioning the death of
innocence
so no it doesn't and i think we have to
be clear that we continue to stand up as
i say for democratic countries where uh
the right to live peacefully in your
sovereign nation is something that
should be respected by all and i know
that liz trust will be continuing to do
what it is the foreign office's job to
do to present uh those arguments and
trying to persuade her colleagues in
india of the merits of uh
giving giving their opinion on putin's
outrage as a legal war when are we going
to
allow more uh ukrainians to come into
our sovereign nation and get rid of the
log jam that seems to be holding up so
many of them who who need our help most
at this very vulnerable time absolutely
and the
two schemes are now from running are
moving at pace i think uh the latest
speakers of the
25 000 uh visas have now been granted
and i know that lord harrington who has
been brought in uh to oversee this is
working uh
literally all hours that god sends to
try and make the process as slick as
possible we have obviously surged uh
more both home office uh and military
support into poland and other locations
to help do the processing uh at pace one
of the challenges one of the things we
have released is that if you have a
passport a ukrainian possible you can do
the biometric checks once you get to the
uk which is a great use and a real help
but of course many ukrainians didn't
have a passport they only had identity
cards
so in which case they do need to be
going to these visa centers in order to
uh get a passport to do that so uh we
are continuing to surge into work and i
think it's about a thousand a day now
being processed which is great news and
you've come to the uk um so i understand
that twenty five thousand visas have now
been issued and i don't have those
figures under okay but it's
significantly less than that
significantly fewer i should say so we
will continue to see i think in the
weeks
talk to me about the golden visas i was
reading in my morning newspapers
that obviously the golden visa scheme
was
under labour but it was ramped up
significantly uh under david cameron's
government uh basically if a russian
oligarch had two million hands to invest
in the uk just for benefit of our views
i'm sure you know uh they were
fast-tracked to come into the uk eight
of them um now have in the prime
minister's words ukrainian blood on
their hands and they've been sanctions
sanctioned what does that say about the
british government's judgment
so uh the sanctions scheme that uh we
have brought in as i say alongside our
us and eu colleagues has been absolutely
rigorous we have made sure that and the
foreign secretary has worked incredibly
uh hard to make sure that all the
sanctions bring our ones that will hold
absolutely firm in the court floor and i
think
we have the highest number of
individuals now sanctioned and i think
what's so important now is that we make
sure that we uh hold everyone firm on
this so there are some who say
if putin just demonstrates that he might
want to step back we should all start to
another these sanctions are there uh to
make it very very clear that putin's war
must fail and putin's behavior is
unacceptable and that the financial
pressures that we are applying both to
him and to those who support him who are
oligarchs regardless of where they
happen to be living now cannot sustain
their lifestyles we will not allow that
in the uk well that doesn't really
answer my question my question is what
does it say about the judgment of the
british government when they're giving
golden visas to people who the prime
minister now says has ukrainian blood on
their hands so historic visas have a
position and of course the key point is
that uh in sanctioning we are making a
very clear statement for the for those
who are uh have demonstrated have well
they do exactly those who have
demonstrably not uh you know come in and
been supporters and worked in the uk and
been perfectly legitimate uh you know
members of our uk society bringing as
you say uh wealth and indeed lots of
experience and business development
those are being sanctioned they have
been punished uh for their relationship
and their support of judgment to let
them in in the first place
well as we say we know we are now
sanctioning those who have very clearly
taken a position with putin but there
are many who have stood up against putin
and who are here uh and have the you
know the protection and the safety of
the uk because they are uh standing
against putin and uh we commend them for
their bravery yeah talking about bad
judgment 20 fines issued as far as
partygate is concerned 20 instances of
the law being broken so far there will
be more were led to believe by the
metropolitan police the prime minister
is still refusing to say that the law
was broken um the deputy prime minister
will stop where you are this time
yesterday morning he said that there
were clear breaches of the law where are
you on that
so the met police as you say kay uh are
continuing their uh review and uh as the
prime minister said we want them to uh
complete uh whatever it is uh the path
that they're going to do and the prime
minister has committed that he will ask
sue gray to do a not sure what we're
going to call it a wrap-up report
looking at
everything that he will come to
parliament to discuss it then so i'm
always been in the case i'd rather let
the professionals get on and uh complete
the work they're doing and then the
sugre
report number two which will be able to
uh put all the evidence that she
gathered uh into the round and indeed uh
for the prime minister to be able to
come and talk to the house at that point
that being said was the law broken
so as i say the uh prime minister has
been clear that he wants to be able to
come back to the house and discuss this
i'm not asking about it well but that's
what that's what do you think so what do
you think so i want to make sure that uh
we let the met police do that without uh
interference from commentary they've
already said twenty times twenty
occasions they've uh issued fixed
penalty notices you get one of those if
you break the law
and so we will see when the full the
full uh completed report is done and sue
gray will then be able to publish hers
we'll be able to uh discuss it in detail
but as the police haven't uh you know
published any names or any lists i think
at the moment i want to let them
continue their work they've told us that
20 on 20 instances the law was broken
why is the prime minister not saying
that
well because the premise is very okay he
wants to wait for the whole process to
what about you how do you feel about do
you think that they're wrong in issuing
these fixed penalty notes i have no
doubt that the police are issuing
notices on the basis so they're always
broken of those evidence and i want to
make sure uh that we can come back to
the house and look at the whole thing in
the round once they have completed uh
their review of the process and that the
sue grey report which i know many
colleagues felt was sort of frustrated
by uh the uh met police involvement can
then look at it in the round and sue
grey's evidence can be presented so the
deputy prime minister the justice
secretary a former lawyer was misspoke
when he said there were clear breaches
of the law no he is the secretary and he
has set out a position i think if you or
i uh get a fine uh we hopefully pay it
and uh uh move on from there and i hope
and i assume uh that those who have been
fined by the police will pay their fines
and that will be uh the punishment that
they have um
why do we get a firm we got to find if
we break the law
so indeed when regulations so
instances of fines being issued means
that 20 instances people have broken the
law
well that's right they've broken the
regulations that were set in that in the
kodak and the police deemed that that
was what they did and therefore they've
been fined according to the prime
minister not saying that because i say
he wants to wait until the whole uh
process of the police uh review that's
been done
well that's the position he's taken but
you agree that they've broken the law
okay uh let's talk about the ochenton
report i mean
i can't even begin to imagine i think my
stomach yeah
stomach virtually awful and we saw some
of the mums i spoke to some of the mums
uh yesterday uh one mum whose child is
brain damaged as a result of what
happened 201 babies died
what should happen to some of the people
that were responsible should there be
prosecutions should people be let go
so i know that um the health secretary
uh said yesterday i'm afraid i didn't
hear his speech but i was able to catch
up on some of it uh that
he wants to make sure that
those uh who were responsible for this i
mean
catastrophic series of failures over so
many years are held to account uh and
does that look like knowing
knowing sadjit will be very firm and
they will be taking the time to look
through and really understand
uh the depth of the of the problems
where where there is real uh you know
culpability and where you know how that
is dealt with and i will leave that to
the health team to do that but i i want
to see uh those who are uh not fit to
deliver uh the you know not delivering
the right care to be helped out i mean
it's just appalling one of the
interesting things that i've caught
briefly as i was able to look at the
report last night was of course this um
fashion is the wrong word but this
direction towards
natural births away from
cesarean's point and interestingly as as
i read it
i realized that when i was in a
fantastic maternity hospital in
newcastle when i had my children
but actually that was that was
culturally normal and actually uh for my
eldest it was a very very difficult
labor uh which you know one has to
question it was that was that the right
choice and i was not given the choice of
a cesarean section at the time which uh
afterwards for a number of reasons might
well have been the best choice and i
read that and thought actually has this
been a culture that has pervaded to the
point where there is a very serious
relation with my child that really you
know really made my my heart sink at the
thought that you know my children are
well unhealthy and i'm very blessed but
actually to think that there are many
for whom those those medical choices
left families either with you know as
you say uh sick children or indeed loss
of their child before i let you go i
just want to ask about jamie wallace
brave young man member of your party
um who has made the comments that he's
made about wanting to be um transgender
um the prime minister supporting him uh
with a tweet
but i just wondered if you if you wanted
to comment on this i'm sure you will um
boris johnson um tweeting his support
but he had also said that the the supper
that he held for some members of the
party a couple of nights ago good
evening ladies and gentlemen or as
kishdama would put it people who were
assigned female or male at birth that
was insensitive
uh you know jokes made at dinners are
made i think is i mean all of us who
know the premises know he has a a very
very warm and affectionate personality
and i think he is genuinely uh you know
proud and affectionate and wants to
support jamie and his his decision to
share uh with the world uh his his
choice uh to
uh
presents himself as trans and i think i
mean he's a lovely young man and we are
hugely hugely proud of him i think you
know this continuing discussion is
is so important but it's also important
that actually at the end they we respect
and love each other uh as how we want to
live our lives i think that's always
what the prime minister wants to try and
achieve uh and we are incredibly proud
of jamie taking on uh you know what will
by definition as a public person uh be a
lot of commentary about his choice and i
think that's incredibly uh brave and you
know we we absolutely cheer him on and
uh want to want to make sure that he can
either be an advocate in this space or
indeed if he chooses to not want to be
an advocate other than just getting on
with being a great mp that's great too
okay we're out of time it would be good
to talk about that in more detail and
perhaps we'll chat to jamie about it in
the fullness of time for now thanks so
much indeed thank you
let's look at the front pages for you
the telegraph carries a quote from the
head of gchq sir jeremy fleming's speech
with claims vladimir putin's advisers
are afraid to tell him the truth about
how russia's invasion of ukraine is
playing out
the ft reports that the german and
austrian governments are poised to
russian gas supplies for russia
and the metro reports on jamie wallace
just chatting about him the conservative
who came out as the uk's uh first openly
transgender mp and also revealed that he
was raped and targeted in blackmail plot
well from tomorrow the majority of
people in england will have to pay for
lateral flow tests the decision has been
criticized by some with the disability
equality charity scope saying the move
shows a total disregard from the
government for the fears and concerns of
people at risk we sent iva to a pharmacy
in southwest london to find out more
from tomorrow you're gonna have to pay
for your lateral flows
yeah officially the free testing ends
tomorrow but in practice i think a lot
of people have found them hard to come
by for a while now including this
pharmacy that hasn't actually had any
for a couple of months now some still
will be eligible for free tests after
tomorrow including the most vulnerable
when they have symptoms but only then
and for a lot of charities including
scope as you mentioned there that's
simply not enough scope has been very
critical accusing the government showing
a total disregard of the fears of um
disabled people because don't forget
these three tests have been a way for
the most vulnerable to be able to return
to their normal lives and without them
many will feel unsafe
and afraid to go out the government
though for their part they say they're
doing this because essentially it's
costing a lot of money this free testing
is costing billions every month and they
feel we're now in a position with the
vaccine and the antiviral medicines to
be able to do this safely
okay thanks very much indeed thank you
iva
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now
and the beckham's london property was
reportedly broken into while members of
the family were at home
david victoria and their daughter harper
are said to be unaware that an intruder
was in the house at the time in a
statement the met police said they were
called to a property in kensington on
tuesday the 1st of march
tributes are pouring in for the wanted
star tom parker who has died at the age
of just 33.
he'd been diagnosed with an inoperable
brain tumor the band rose to fame in
2009 and had two number one singles glad
you came and all-time low after they
disbanded in 2014 they once again
reunited last year for a charity benefit
when tom tells guy news he was feeling a
lot better
i think with this disease you get quite
a natural
decline but if anything
it seems to be on the incline i feel a
lot better than i did a couple months
ago
but yeah
just with my increasing health getting
better
um what worry today i'm here today
well ed sheeran has led the music
industry in paying tribute to tom parker
following his passing on wednesday in an
instagram post ed said it's so sad to
hear of tom's passing thoughts and love
for with kelsey
his children and his family very sad day
what a lovely guy
tom as i said died at the age of just 33
he passed away peacefully surrounded by
his family
and his friends
and sad news from the world of hollywood
too bruce willis is retiring from his
30-year long career after being
diagnosed with a brain condition here he
[Music]
in a statement the star's daughter rumor
confirmed that her father as aphasia
which is a condition which affects the
ability to speak
write
and understand language
well in a post to her instagram
followers she wrote with much
consideration bruce is stepping away
from the career that has meant so much
to him we are moving through this as a
strong family unit and wanted to bring
his fans in because we know how much he
means to you as you do to him as bruce
always says
live it up and together we plan to do
just that love emma demi rumor scout
tallulah mabel and evelyn
sad news indeed quick look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
northerly wind will make it cold
everywhere and will bring some snow
mainly to the hills western parts are
largely dry and clear now but there are
wintry showers in the north and the east
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news for
you this morning the uk's top spy chief
sir jeremy fleming who's the director of
gchq says vladimir putin has made a
massive misjudgment on the capabilities
of his own military might
90 of people say their food bill has
taken a hike as the uk prepares for gas
and electricity bills to rise
from
tomorrow it's been revealed that will
smith was asked to leave the oscars
ceremony after slapping chris rock but
refused as the comedian breaks his
silence
foreign secretary liz tross heads to
india today as part of a wider
diplomatic push on the war in ukraine a
trip coincides with her russian
counterpart sergey lavrov also heading
to the country earlier i asked the
international trade secretary anne-marie
trevelyan how she feels about trade
talks with india with the nation notably
reluctant to comment on russia's
offensive in ukraine
it's really important
that we see india we understand why
they've chosen to sit on the fence at
the moment they
you know have
connections in both directions but uh
for us it's really important to see all
countries who believe in democracy and
the rule of law uh and indeed defending
your own territorial borders and wanting
to have that sovereignty you know
respected by those around you to stand
up for that but does it really sit
comfortably with you doing business with
a country that by a mission is
sanctioning the death of innocence
uh so no it doesn't and i think we have
to be clear that we continue to stand up
as i say for democratic countries where
the right to live peacefully in your
sovereign nation is something that
should be respected by all and i know
that liz trust will be continuing to do
what it is the foreign office's job to
do to present those arguments are trying
to persuade her colleagues in india of
the merits of uh
giving giving their opinion on putin's
outrage as a legal war
thrilled to say tamara's here she's
going on holiday next week so make the
most of her what did you make of that
morning kay well it was interesting
wasn't it liz trust is in india what can
she achieve there given that india is
traditionally an ally of moscow refused
to condemn the ukraine invasion at the
united nations and buys a lot of russian
arms and oil and sergey lavrov raga
rather awkwardly is on his first visit
since the invasion began trying to
convince the indians to buy even more
russian oil liz trust will say
democracies need to work together india
of course is the world's largest
democracy but there's these big nato and
g7 meetings next week india of course
not in either of those but they want
india to be on side joe biden's been
pretty vocal saying india's position on
this is shaky but not clear that she's
going to achieve very much through that
visit despite the charm offensive the
government is um engaging in in order to
try and get a trade deal with india
behind the scenes and anne marie
trevelyan as good as confirmed that that
carries on regardless
party gauge
is it against the law what they've been
doing or not boris johnson says it was
not his understanding and those words
his understanding are very important
that the rules were broken at the time
so we can sort of see the outlines of
his defense there if it is to those
claims that he lied to
parliament that he it was his
understanding no parties had taken place
of course the difficulty is that he's
accused of attending six of the twelve
the met are investigating um at the
moment the government's line is uh
slightly confusing but all will become
clear once the police investigation is
concluded okay for now thanks very much
tomorrow's take nine o'clock looking
forward to it joining us now is general
lord richard dannett former chief of the
general staff hello to my law thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning um are we taking at face value
what the russians are telling us in the
form of president putin that they are
moving back from cities like kiev
well i think we have to um
watch and see what's going on that'll
help us um understand whether we can
believe him i think what is uh happening
is that
they are making much of the fact that
they are going to withdraw at least some
of their units around kiev but in fact i
think what they're doing is
consolidating their positions um a
number of their units have got quite
isolated they got quite a long way
forward so they're withdrawing those a
number of being taken out of combat
altogether because they've been pretty
heavily heavily hit but i think what
we're where we can believe them is the
fact that the main effort of their
campaign
is now switching from the failed rapid
strike to affect regime change by
capturing keeve and they're switching it
to the donbass and
in a sense this is fairly logical a
little bit unsurprising given that since
2014 they have been fighting in those
two eastern provinces to try and take
control of them so i think they're now
realizing
the difficult situation they're in i
think they're now realizing the poor
performance of their military and are
reassessing what they can achieve in
this campaign and uh cutting their
losses and putting their main effort
their focus on the donbass region
bearing in mind also they will continue
to create this land corridor from crimea
through mario paul to the donbass itself
could we move to um the comments uh by
the gch q heads sir jeremy fleming
saying that putin's advisers are lying
to him about how badly they are doing
what credence should we give to that and
also
i suppose the flip side of that could be
that if that is the case putin may ramp
up the war
well i think that's quite possible what
is interesting is that now the
intelligence authorities of the uk and
and the us are saying what many of us
who have been observing um have begun to
believe that putin must have been misled
by his generals and by his security
staff as to the capability of his armed
forces before this campaign started and
i think he's been shielded to an extent
from the
harsh reality
of what's been going on at the front so
he has believed that his own military is
more capable than it's turned out to be
now you touch on the question does that
mean that he's still in the dark about
the reality and he's going to order one
more push if you like or is he going to
accept where he is
uh and um and change the plan and if you
take their published statements it would
look as if he is going to change the
plan they're going to consolidate if not
completely withdraw from the north and
west of kyiv but make their main effort
as i said a moment or two ago in the
donbass region which is where they've
been fighting since 2014.
yeah
meantime mercenaries are being brought
in from places like syria and uh
chechnya's we're told being offered
seven thousand dollars to go to the
front line um
we're hearing that syrian soldiers are
accepting that money in order to try to
pay uh to feed their families uh back
home in syria that but i suppose the
other way of looking at it is that they
are likely to become cannon fodder
well okay i think sadly that is probably
right um
i'm not sure whether syrian soldiers who
are used to different kind of conditions
um really will be able to make much of a
meaningful contribution in the ukrainian
um the late winter early spring and i'm
just throwing
soldiers individual soldiers into the
fight without them being in coordinated
and well-trained units is tantamount as
you suggest to making them cannon fodder
i think it's also a reflection on the
fact that the
russians are short of manpower
we probably
all got too used to thinking that the
russian army is huge it's large like it
was in the cold war days it's not like
that at all and
this force of 190 000 that they
assembled and pushed in
four five six weeks ago was if you like
almost the cream of the of the russian
army and a lot of that has now been
battered and been dented and manpower is
is an issue and i think it's a sign of
approaching desperation that they're
willing to offer seven thousand dollars
to syrians to come and join their fight
i'm afraid a lot of those syrians will
actually die pretty quickly in the harsh
surroundings of ukraine
yeah uh i'm afraid we must leave it
there my lord because we need to make
room uh for the president of the ukraine
speaking to the australian parliament
thank you this morning thank you
thank you
yes it has never been that a country
would block
the whole city for
other vessels of any country
but this is exactly what was done by
russia
part of the black and as of sea
is is a dead sea these days any vessel
that we try to come in
can simply be destroyed by the russian
navy
more than hundreds of
trade
vessels under different flags have been
blocked by russia in our ports
for dozens of years we haven't seen this
in the world
for a country to start the war against
the neighboring country openly
declaring their enslavement or
destruction
not to leave even the name of that
nation not to have even any opportunity
for this nation to leave to live
freely the worst pages of the 20th
century have been brought back by russia
already the biggest threats of that
century came back the evil that humanity
thought they had forgotten about a long
time ago but the most terrible thing if
we don't stop russia now if
we don't hold russia
accountable then some other countries of
the world who are
looking forward to the similar war
against their neighbors will decide that
such things are possible for them as
well
the fate of the global security is
decided now
no one
can
manage winds or precipitations it means
no one can save
any part of the world from
radioactive contamination which will
come if
nuclear weapons are used no country in
the world can theoretically
should
not have even a theoretical possibility
of blocking
um
trade
fleet
and block the seats for other countries
there shouldn't be even a theoretical
possibility to do so no leader of the
world can
count
on being unpunishable if he's thinking
about a prospective war
ladies and gentlemen the nation of
australia after the
more than a month of the full-fledged
war
against
russia
we can surely say that there is no only
way of bringing the global security
as bringing russia to peace and silence
and responsibility and accountability
for everything that russia has done
against the global security the country
which is using the nuclear blackmailing
should receive the sanctions
which would show that such blackmailing
is destructive for the blackmailer
itself it has to be an effective toolkit
to hold responsible any country which is
blocking
the
trade navigation
so for no one to have a temptation
to close any sea and making the dead sea
out of them so far we don't have such
instruments so the leadership the
leadership of australia
can be paramount for the global
security which is now strengthening but
our anti-war coalition which is working
on bringing the war the peace back to
ukraine we need to also enhance the
capabilities of the international
institutions
which were created to hold
military war criminals okay
we will uh move away from the discussion
between president zilinski speech by
president zielinski to the australian
parliament and bring you more later on i
just want to highlight this for you you
may be planning your easter holidays
because they're just around the corner
aren't they some of you may be thinking
of booking a staycation somewhere scenic
perhaps involving a bit of a hike well
here in the uk we're lucky to have some
of the most stunning mountain ranges in
the world but whilst they're beautiful
they can also be very dangerous joined
now by sean roberts principal at
glenmore lodge scotland's national
outdoor training center hello to sean
thanks very much indeed for joining us
on the programme this morning we have
seen um some deaths both at ben nevis
and indeed snowden over the last few
days and weeks what's driving the
increase do you think
well and you know sadly um this this
winter we have seen deaths in that in
our mountains and there's there's always
a range of um
factors that link into every incident
okay uh many of them uh this winter have
been some of the hard snowpack that
we've had and and obviously any slip or
trip has very serious consequences but i
know i'm in shadow this morning but we
were keen for everyone to see the the
snowy conditions we have at the moment
so our winter mountains are in full
winter conditions and there'd be many
many people thousands of people
preparing to head to the hills this
morning and all of those i'm sure will
be having a great day out there there's
safe days to be had with the right
planning and preparation
and what do you need to look we can see
the difference there between the two
scenes what are your top tips for people
who are thinking about heading to the
mountains over easter
so we would just ask people to have a
very progressive approach with their
planning and and within that ask
ourselves the what where the who and why
so what information do you need so we
obviously you need the weather um most
weather forecasts that we see on the
telly is a sea level weather forecast we
expect conditions to be perhaps windier
colder on the tops of our mountains
perhaps wetter as well so always hunt
out a mountain weather forecast there
are many available on the internet
through the met office or the mountain
weather information service now as you
can see behind me it is winter at the
moment so in scotland we have the
scottish avalanche information service
so again if you're coming north to the
highlands please seek out have a look at
the app be avalanche aware and there's
great information there to help you plan
now obviously where you go we need to
relate back to the weather so you know
always aim to plan to get the most from
your journey so try and you know try and
con correspond your journey to where
the weather is perhaps a little bit more
benign or where you're avoiding some of
the avalanche hazards so yesterday on
our mountains we had
low avalanche hazards
and today with the new snowfall we have
moderate avalanche hazards but again
that information is all there to help
you navigate and negotiate around and of
course as we look at the cloud behind me
the ability to navigate is going to be
really central to a successful journey
on the mountains absolutely now if you
want navigator that relies on technology
please please make sure that you have
backup in terms of battery but you're
always slightly vulnerable if you're
just relying on mapping on a phone for
example and we always advocate map and
compass if you're heading for the hills
oh really good advice sean thanks very
much indeed and make sure you're dressed
for the weather thanks sean much
appreciated
no thanks kay thank you
well what's believed to be the uk's
oldest mountain rescue dog is being
honoured with a so-called animal obe
here they are 15 year old border collie
skye hello
um
carried out around 200 searches during
her 11 year career working in all
weathers to help locate missing people
in the lake district today she'll become
the 36th animal to receive the pdsa
order of merit
good for you skye and she's 11 years old
still working up walking up those
mountains
nothing
now
mother of baby p who died after months
of abuse back in 2007 could be freed
from jail after a parole board ruled
that she's now eligible for release
joining us is criminologist and head of
psychology at birmingham city university
and that's craig jackson hello to mr
jackson thank you for joining us on the
programme uh we're told that she has a
low risk of reoffending how is how
difficult is it for somebody who has
carried out such a monstrous crime to be
rehabilitated
well the parole board take their duty
very seriously as you can imagine they
have approximately 25 000 cases of
prisoners who come up for parole every
year and the recruitment and training
process is quite rigorous for staff who
join the parole board whether they're
psychologists psychiatrists
members from the probation panel of
probation team or social workers um they
do they do know that the risks are there
and that no decision made by a parole
board is 100
safe but of course they base their
decisions on expert interviews on expert
testimony as well as face-to-face oral
panels with the prisoners too
and i think we should remember that of
the 25 000 cases that come across the
desk of the staff at the parole board
each year they end up interviewing and
speaking
to only about 5 000 of those and
only about half of those are successful
in being released and about another 10
or 12 percent
go to open prisons
so we're looking at a relatively small
number of offenders who reoffend each
year based on pre-pandemic statistics
we're looking at about
60 individuals who've reoffended after
they've been released or sent to open
prison
so this the number itself the absolute
number is quite small but obviously
we're concerned about the most extreme
offenders and those like conley who've
been convicted of very very shocking
crimes that go against what we believe
the order of society should be
yeah um how once they've made their
decision can that be overturned i mean
we have heard that the justice secretary
deputy prime minister dominic roberts
said he would be asking the board to
reconsider
the process for challenging the
decisions made by the parole board is
there and it's been there
pretty much in the form that it exists
in since about the 90s when the parole
board became
as independent as
it could be
you can apply for a review if you are a
victim or you are connected to the case
in some way but there's also the ability
for a judicial review so the justice
secretary is perfectly within his right
to do this and most cases of release do
come across the desk of the justice
secretary or his office one way or
another so there's nothing particularly
unusual in the action he's taken but of
course it's it's a politically shrewd
move to do that just to try and double
check and second guess that the parole
board's decision
is as safe as it can be given the
circumstances of connelly's complex
background and her offending
and how difficult is it for somebody
like tracy connolly to come back into
society she'll need to change her name
i'm guessing and where she lives
how difficult is it for somebody who's
carried out such
monstrous crimes to be rehabilitated
themselves
it's not an easy process when you work
with offenders such as connolly you've
got to look into their backgrounds and
indeed
miss connolly's background her childhood
was not a particularly good one and
social service work social services were
aware of her and she was
sent to an approved school and and
various problems with family members so
her background is very complex and and
messy
but when you're working with offenders
to try and challenge and ultimately
change dangerous behaviors such as the
one she exhibited it takes a long time
to unpick what they did their behaviors
their behavioral patterns their
attitudes and their personality
and one of the first things you have to
do is get the offender to admit their
offense and what they did was wrong
now we do know that that connolly was
released from prison previously on
parole in about 2013
and unfortunately she was sent back to
prison because she breached the
conditions of her parole thankfully she
hadn't committed any offences or contact
offenses against others but she broke
the terms of a parole license and was
recalled back to custody
so
in one way we can argue that the system
does work
the the decision made by the parole
board at the time was wrong
but it was rectified and corrected and
she did go back into custody that of
course is something that the parole
board will have considered
in their latest decision
we need to remember that when we're
looking at behaviorally we're out of
time so we're going to have to leave it
there so we'll leave it on that thought
but thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the program much
appreciated thank you